at a rally like this
it's true free brady man he's a [ __ ]
winner man five rings
so that's true so i'm just gonna assume
these are guys i'm kidding guys
all right so uh we are here live to
mother of all patriot rallies as you
know
a lot of contentious issues you've got
daca
you've got immigration you got the wall
and of course you got roger goodell
that prick so uh
what brought you guys out today we gotta
highlight the issues that matter we
gotta get goodell out of there
unite america against roger goodell it's
an issue we can all agree on
now you see i feel that these guys have
found the real villain
in american uh in american civilization
right now i'm gonna ask you guys a
couple questions
um you know there's a lot of right
wingers here there are some people
and uh we had some questions uh is there
a race and why is it asians
well i i don't know about that fire get
out all i know is
fargo okay we're here to speak on the
issues okay
magnets how do they work
[Music]
good stuff keeps the world going all
right i have a question
how can social justice warriors and
these right-wingers find common ground
and why is it rick and morty
everybody agrees common ground everybody
can get behind
fire and roger goodell they are
dedicated to the real issues
all right i'll ask you uh who would win
in a tag team wrestling match
insane clown posse or kyle chapman and
sam hyde
oh man that's a tough one if any side
has roger goodell they're not winning
yeah whoever signs tom brady first yeah
five rings
five things soon to be six
these guys hate goodell with the
dedication that antifa hates trump it's
amazing how much
they hate goodell i hate him too though
let's uh let's be real here
um i meant a
level of dedication and say come on
you're putting words in my mouth
uh our traps are what the traps
yeah like really really good looking
they're basically girls with a penis oh
i know it's fired
up can they play in the nfl are they
eligible i think that we've got
um you know their issue out there for
you folks fire goodell he's a piece of
[ __ ]
i got a gift for you guys just for
taking part in this uh
a little parting gift in honor of the
juggalo march on washington
faygo soda unfortunately you guys have
to share one
but uh thank you guys so much for coming
on our show